el presidente francés emmanuel macrón se
ha convertido en el blanco de ataques en
varios países de mayoría musulmana desde
turquía hasta pakistán y miles de
musulmanes han llamado al boicot de
productos franceses y acusan al
mandatario de islamofóbico por sus
declaraciones en defensa del laicismo y
su plan contra el islamismo radical con
una inusual serie de tuits en tres
idiomas inglés francés y árabe el jefe
de estado trató de calmar las tensiones
no nos rendiremos nunca respetamos todas
las diferencias con un espíritu de paz
no aceptamos el discurso de odio y
defendemos un debate razonable siempre
estaremos del lado de la dignidad humana
y de los valores universales en francia-
residen cerca de 6 millones de
musulmanes y el islám se ha convertido
en la segunda religión con mayor número
de fieles en el país sin embargo según
una encuesta realizada a petición del
gobierno hace un año el 42% de los
musulmanes franceses se sienten
discriminados por su religión un racismo
tácito que dificulta su integración en
la sociedad francesa
dt gays xytex
el terrorismo y la amistad tiene una
agenda que está escrita es llevar a cabo
ataques para que los musulmanes sean
estigmatizados y eso lleva a un mayor
terrorismo y radicalización es
exactamente en estos pasos que el
gobierno de muchas fuerzas políticas se
están tomando hoy y de hecho ya hemos
visto una serie de actos contra los
musulmanes y lugares de culto
y si bien el impacto comercial del
boicot se prevé limitado al mandatario
le preocupa la imagen de francia como
país hostil al islam y marcaron más el
estigma y la discriminación estructural
sobre las comunidades musulmanas en el
país